wide truck driver shortage it is
unfortunately worsening like other parts
of our economy drivers are part of the
so-called great resignation being a
truck driver is a very tough job it's
long nights on the road you're away from
home for a long time but hector mahia is
reporting live this morning with more on
the continuing effect of this driver
shortage on our supply chain hector good
morning to you
good morning guys and we are told demand
is at an all-time high seeing greater
demand now than before the pandemic and
as you can imagine that's just adding to
the number of issues creating those
slowdowns at the ports now in terms of
the number of jobs
the industry is still down about 80 000
drivers all across the country that's
according to the nevada trucking
association to address the shortage
federal officials are considering
allowing a limited number of truck
drivers under the age of 21 to cross
state lines the department of
transportation is also providing funding
for states to improve
their commercial driving license process
trucking moves over 72 percent of all
freight
here in nevada that number is
95.3 percent we don't have a mississippi
river we don't have an extensive rail or
pipeline network
so as they used to say hector if you got
it a truck brought it
so there's not one economic sector that
the trucking industry doesn't touch
we're talking about mining manufacturing
casinos grocery stores hospitals bottom
line it affects all of us so this
morning we're live right across the
street from a truck stop and we're told
that in addition to the truck driver
shortage there's also a truck shortage
we'll talk about that issue still ahead
in the next half hour reporting live
hector mejia live local now